so donald trump has started a new
routine where he calls
into fox and friends every monday
morning fox and friends of course is
this fox propaganda
morning show uh the format is two male
hosts and a female host and it's kind of
like a mix of
uh completely hair brain depraved
propaganda with the optics of
daytime television and the idea of trump
calling in every monday is that it's
ostensibly
good for everybody fox and friends hosts
get their face time with the president
trump gets a softball interview
and everybody is better for it other
than the country and the world
but sadly it did not go super well
yesterday we're going to look at a few
clips and check out the looks on the
faces of the hosts of fox
and friends when trump goes into these
bizarre
screeds and unconscionable diatribes the
looks on the faces of the hosts
are of people sick to their stomachs and
it actually reminded me watching these
clips
of when remember when uh former new
jersey governor chris christie
dropped out of the republican primary in
2016
and then endorsed trump and like the
next day showed up and stood behind
trump during one of these stump speeches
and chris christie just looked like he
had eaten a bad oyster he looked sick
same idea here with the fox host so get
let's get right into it
trump was asked about of course ruth
bader ginsburg
and what is trump's rationale for trying
to
push through her replacement before
election day
and trump's answer was well democrats
would do it if given the chance
trump also you will notice has a
terrible phone connection might even be
on speaker phone just everything going
wrong don't forget we were put in this
position by
voters and we have a lot of time it's
not like we have two days we have a lot
of time as this goes
whether it's before or after i think it
should we have a lot of time before
i think it should go before but whether
it's before or
after i mean after we have a lot of time
but i think we should do it before but
we you know
so you might do it we're in the same
position there is zero chance that they
wouldn't do it just so you have to see
you're putting it on the back so if the
shoe were on the other foot
if they if there was a democratic
president in a democrat senate you think
they would
they would definitely fill the seat
before
oh zero chance that they wouldn't they
would do it they wouldn't even talk
about it
fox and friends host ainsley earhart
there trying to help trump out
now this is a terrible argument trump
has
run the country and campaigned for years
on elect me because i won't do what
democrats do
elect me because i won't do what
democrats would
do if given the chance and now trump
says well the reason i'm going to do
this is democrats would do it
i thought the point was you don't behave
like democrats
you say democrats do the wrong thing and
now
you're justifying your actions by saying
well it's what democrats would do
very backwards logic but unfortunately
for the fox crowd they eat it up like
it's being ladle fed to them
maybe the most disgusting moment of the
interview
donald trump sort of laughed off ruth
bader ginsburg's
dying wish that she not be replaced
until a new president has been seated
inaugurated
donald trump without any evidence
whatsoever this is sick
says i don't know if that's true adam
schiff
might have made that up out of thin air
nancy pelosi
might have made that up out of thin air
take a look at this charlie was on our
show earlier and he said we have an
obligation to our to our voters
to vote the way they want us to vote
that's why they put us in office so he's
gonna push to to go ahead and fill the
seat um
either before the election or in the
lame duck session then you have
ruth bader ginsburg who told her her
granddaughter on her deathbed allegedly
that she
her dying wish was to have the next
president choose her successor
how do you think all this plays out
well i don't know that she said that or
was that written out by adam schiff and
schumer and pelosi i i would be more
inclined to the second okay you know
that came
out of the wind it sounds so beautiful
but that sounds like a schumer deal or
maybe a pelosi or
or a shifty shift so that came out of
the winds let's see i mean maybe she did
it maybe she did
look the bottom line is we won the
election of course
no doubt whatsoever there there's no
reason to think
that the official story is false if it
were
a made-up story it certainly wouldn't be
trump who could tell us oh it was adam
schiff who came up with the story
imagine the absurdity of this claim
ruth bader ginsburg didn't really say
what she said on her
deathbed a random congressman from
california
adam schiff made it up disgusting
absolutely disgusting and again you look
at the online pro-trump enclaves they
they actually say yeah you know trump
might be onto something here
sounds fake doesn't sound real with 200
000 now dead from coronavirus and we're
going to talk more about this actually
204 thousand
donald trump says during this bizarre
interview
we've turned the corner on the pandemic
and trump grades his coronavirus
response an
a-plus this was as they were talking uh
uh
the stock market futures down 700 points
because of the resurgence of the virus
that's expected trump saying we get an
a-plus take a look
you're going to get on air force one
you're flying out to ohio today you're
going to address the
fight for the american worker uh ever
since the pandemic
started and the economy cratered uh the
federal reserve
you know looking forward they were a
little pessimistic but a couple of days
ago
the federal reserve actually was quite
optimistic and in fact
they talked about how right now we're in
a situation where we have
three million more jobs than they
thought we would at this
stage of the game that's right and 600
billion dollars more
economic activity over and above what
they expected just three months ago
so while we are still suffering from the
pandemic there is some light at the end
of the tunnel
so we're rounding the corner with or
without a vaccine they hate it when i
say that but that's the way it is we're
rounding the corner
on the pandemic and we've done a
phenomenal job not just a good job a
phenomenal job other than public
relations but that's because i have fake
news i can't you know you
you can't convince them of anything
they're fake but
we have done on on public relations i
give myself a d
on the job itself we take an a plus a
plus trump says on the virus now
reminders
let's come back to earth cases per
capita the us's 12th highest in the
world
if you take out tiny territories the
us's
eighth highest in the world in cases per
capita
deaths per capita 10th highest in the
world
is the united states eighth highest in
the world
if you exclude tiny territories trump
says i get an a-plus
trump admits later in this interview
that he is playing politics in
considering
who to replace ruth bader ginsburg with
looking at michigan looking at florida
admitting it
action day so maybe she gets the nod is
is politics going to be part of it
i try not to say so i think probably
automatically it is even if you're not
wanting to do that it becomes a little
automatic a great one from michigan
you know you talked that as you know
indiana
represented very well we have uh from
all over the country
i think less so than the person
themselves if you look at
and then trump jokes because everything
is a joke
everything is a game everything is a
popularity contest
trump jokes about putting fox and
friends host
ainslie earhart on the supreme court
after saying that you know ruth bader
ginsburg did support me in her decision
once everything with trump is what have
you done for him
she was you know a legendary a legal
figure i'm sure you have some things
you'd like to say about
how this woman had given decades of her
life to public service
well she was a legend and she
represented something different than
you or i or somebody else may really
agree with or
were like frankly but she was a legend
she represented
a certain philosophy policy
certain groups of laws she represented
them very well
i highly respected she actually voted
for me in a very important case
and i was shocked if you want another
truth because we lost
a couple of conservative votes and she
actually made it possible to get this
approved which was rather amazing to be
honest with you i
i don't want to hurt her reputation at
all but she did vote for me in a case
that was a very important case
so that was nice but no she was the
legendary figure
well i know you said you're going to
nominate a woman that's very important
to
uh women who are voting in november uh
for women's rights
you said you angelie i could nominate
you you know you don't have to be
good you don't have to be a lawyer you
don't have to be a judge i could
nominate do you want to make some news
right now
funny guy right but but again it's not a
joke that with trump it's always about
what did the person do for me what can i
expect them to do for me
what do they think about me do they like
me have they helped me
that's what matters to trump and i i
again i don't know if these fox and
friends interviews do any good do any
harm
but they are stunning from the
standpoint of
basic human decency it didn't get much
better
later last night at one of donald
trump's two rallies in ohio let's talk
about that briefly next
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
pacman